you know going through the internet and
I all of a sudden I see Florio's posted
this about full-time officials and does
this have anything to do with gambling
and the patent preowned the fact that
maybe we're going to expand the regular
season to 18 games I go and pretty good
Florio on I need details here so Mike
where do you want to start regular
season or what these full-time officials
mean as far as perception and is it
attached to gambling well I think what
the full-time officials it is
fascinating bad because remember it's
been five years since the lockout that
ended after that fail mary game on
Monday night the Packers Seahawks the
embarrassment that sparked the NFL to
finally get a deal done with the
officials part of that deal from 2012
was the ability to have full-time
officials but it took five years to get
to the point where they finalized the
plan because it's expensive to have
full-time employees file with legalized
gambling coming and one or the other
there's a sense that it's coming either
through the courts to Congress however
it happens it's going to happen and the
NFL understands that they need to
enhance the perception that they're
doing everything they can to get the
calls right it's one thing to have some
goofy call that screws up the point
spread and millions of dollars changes
hands through illegal gambling once that
starts happening under the umbrella of
legalized gambling that's when the
politician starts sniffing around that's
when people start really criticizing the
sport and the NFL have to be ready to do
everything it can to create the sense
that we're doing all we can to get these
calls right and ultimately eliminating
as many mistakes as possible but you
have I think 124 officials in the NFL 24
are going to be full-time officials how
does that work in the hierarchy of if
you're a full-time official are you
getting better games what do you do as a
full-time official that may be Ed
Hochuli is not doing in the offseason
helped me out with the gray area yeah
and there's there is a lot of gray there
there is a lot of looseness in this
where there isn't going to be some
mandatory assignment of Ed Hochuli hey
you're going to be full-time they're
going to take volunteers they're going
to they're going to let guys have other
employment as long as they recognize the
NFL is their full-time employer I mean I
think they're trying to do this in a way
where it's been
steps its experimentation its perception
and ultimately you're still going to
have the vast majority of workforce that
isn't full-time out does it continue to
move toward full-time maybe it will
especially when you consider yes it's
expensive to have these folks as
full-time employees but if the NFL plays
this legalized gambling card the right
way they are going to make not just
millions more per year they're going to
make billions more per year they're
going to be able to afford full-time
officials across the board but for now
it's just going to be some there's going
to be a limit to how many per any given
crew or full time they'll be primarily
utilized between the end of the season
in May 15 and yeah again I make any
effort any focus that the part-time
officials give on top of what they're
already providing the league is a good
thing it's not going to iron out all the
mistakes but it does enhance the
perception that the NFL is trying to get
all the calls right but what's the
downside to this as I look at if let's
say a part-time official makes a mistake
or god forbid a full-time official makes
a mistake and are we going to be alerted
to who is a full-time and who is a
part-time official oh I have a feeling
that information will ultimately be
available and won't that be part of the
analysis when there's a blunder and that
person's name gets thrown out there
remember there were those series of
mistakes whether it was clock management
whether it was a bad call at the back of
the end zone where the Seahawks player
hit the ball out of bounds and the
official looking right at it real didn't
realize that that should have been
flagged these are all things that the
first question is going to be is that a
full-timer
or is that a part-timer and text a
danger of dipping your toe in this water
eventually you got to do a cannonball
into it and I think that's why we're
heading in that direction they're laying
the foundation now with a limited number
of officials so that once gambling is
legal we won't have that distinction I
think we're going to be willing to
tolerate the distinction for now but by
the time there is legalized gambling it
may be a 20-year proposition it's still
coming and by the time it happens that's
when you're going to have all of them
full-time employees this was also posted
on pro football talk by Mike Florio
joining us Roger Goodell recent comments
regarding the preseason serve as a clear
reminder that
League still wants to swap fewer
preseason games for more regular-season
games
what's the big hurdle here well the big
hurdle is getting the players to buy
into it without the league being public
in its effort to try to persuade people
that there should be more regular-season
game
it used to be when Roger Goodell would
trash the preseason the obvious follow
was well we have 20 total games let's
have fewer preseason games and more
regular-season games but at some point
the league recognized it's kind of hard
to reconcile player health and safety
with wanting more regular-season games
so they need the players to come to the
bargaining table the next time they
negotiate their labor deal and they need
the players to be the ones who say we're
ready to play more games in the regular
season we're ready to come up with a
plan to make it happen it has to come
from the players but when the
commissioner says anything about the
preseason that's the deeper messages
they want to expand the regular season
because then they have a power right now
they want it to the league does to cut
the preseason but they're not going to
take away preseason games and go from 20
total games to 19 or 18 they want to
replace a preseason game with a
regular-season game and he specifically
mentioned three which I think we read
the math is simple three preseason 17
regular season eight home games eight
road games one neutral site game in the
past that's been dismissed but maybe
that's the end result here and that's
the middle ground between 16 and 18 but
revenue comes into play here and usually
that play cage the players is it is you
know you get an extra game check is that
what we're looking at here well it's an
extra game check it's a bigger pie and
and also I think part of this would have
to be bigger rosters I think that's how
you get the players to buy in because as
we hear more and more about the
long-term health effects playing
football you start adding regular-season
games you're adding more opportunities
to go out there get injured get head
trauma get things that will be
problematic for you later in life so
it's really going to have to be a
package of benefits beyond that extra
game check it make the players believe
hey you know what this is a good idea
for us to do this but again it can't
come from the lead it has to be the
league hoping or at least working the
back channels to get the Union to be the
one that says
we think this works we're behind it
because if the league is behind it I
think that across the board people are
going to stand up and reject one other
item here and had somebody who's working
with the company who's trying to develop
a new helmet I think you were talking
about the Seattle Seahawks who have been
sort of at the forefront of this give us
an idea what this helmet is all about
and how is it going to change the sport
yeah we're going to see this vises
helmet a lot this year Doug Baldwin
Richard Sherman others using it it's got
kind of a cushy exterior shell an
Outlook no helmet is going to eliminate
concussions because a lot of concussions
happen when the body is moving at a
certain rate of speed and all of a
sudden the body stops and the brain
bounces off the inside of the skull but
to the extent that they're taking
advantage of technologies to try to come
up with a helmet that can reduce the
number of head injuries you get from
getting hit with a helmet then that is
part of this broader process to make the
game as safe as possible it's never
going to be completely safe but you know
and it literally gets criticized a lot
but think back the way football was 20
years ago and look at how it is now
there have been a lot of advances in the
past ten years to make a game safer any
shows and one way to make the game safer
is to come up with a better helmet even
though you have to acknowledge there's
no way you're going to get rid of all
concussions because of the fact that it
is a matter of the brain hitting the
inside skull thank you Mike I appreciate
it as always all right I hate we got
four weeks until we get started yep
we're good yeah we're going to be up
there with Bill Belichick acknowledge
you and me oh hell no okay I mean me or
your hell not okay I didn't think so
because what happens is Rodney and Tony
and I will be standing together on the
football field and then Belichick walks
by and gives Rodney a big hug and then
he'll shake Tony's hand and then I'm the
third guy so then I have to quickly act
like I'm doing something else like
looking at my notes so it's not that
awkward as Belichick walks by and
grumbles something under his breath so
maybe I'll turn to you and we'll just
talk to one another hey the best one was
last December at MetLife Stadium on a
Saturday night when and Dominick and Sue
came over to say hi to Tony and and he
gave Rodney a look
that I did was I wish I would have had
my phone going at a time it was great
and you know what Rodney's not afraid of
anybody you know no no I was I wish I
would have been close enough that I
could have tried to add to table oh good
stuff thank you Mike
I see but pro football talk.com the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience